c'est un peu la main j'ai pris ma
première ceinture internationale devant
70 personnes aux états unis donc c'est
quelque chose d'exceptionnel et
j'étais très content d'avoir d'avoir
d'avoir gagné devant autant de monde
les grandes ici dans le 19ème
arrondissement à stalingrad
c'est un quartier qui était assez chaud
assez chaud pas ce qui est pas mal de
deux dealers et c'est pas mal de toxico
donc ce n'était pas facile de grandir
entre guillemets dans un pertinent le
samu et ce qui est bien c'est qu'on
avait des grands frères ce qu'on appelle
les grands frères c'est évident est
toujours là pour nous aiguiller toujours
là pour me conseiller
si vous manquez de quoi que ce soit il
est là pour nous dire voilà tient fait
attention aux bêtises etc et c'est super
important
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui en tant que
jeune décès de giving back de donner ce
qu'on m'a donnée en étant en étant plus
jeune et puis surtout de ne pas oublier
d'où je viens donc la c1
l'école élémentaire où j'étais on était
très souvent dirigées vers le foot et
j'ai pas duré très longtemps foot parce
que c'est ce qu'on nous propose et en
étant jeune tout en nous proposait le
foot et puis voilà
lorsque je suis parti au collège là je
voulais vraiment faire un sport vraiment
choisir un sport n'était pas un grand
joueur je faisais un peu je n'étais pas
un grand jeu et puis au delà de ça c'est
que voilà je voulais faire autre chose
si on était un sport
un sport où moi j'ai quelqu'un de très
posé très calme etc
je pense que la boxe ça m'a permis
d'extérioriser pas mal de choses et c
est la boxe est une thérapie en soit
cette thérapie c'est un sport qui est
excellent qui vécu énormément de valeur
de respect respect de soi respect
d'autrui respect de tous ceux qui sont
autour de nous le dépassement de soi la
confiance le énormément de choses
énormes ça on arrive au collège aux
connaisseurs jeunesse celle entre le
troisième jeu ne seront pas 4e ou 3e je
commence avec un contenu que je commence
la bosse j'ai commencé la boxe dans le
9ème arrondissement m cadets
plus derrière c'est un amour pour ce
sport et d'où l'importance d'avoir un
bon éducateur ça fait toute la
différence
lorsqu'on a beaucoup de gens bons
éducateurs qui sait de 30 mètres
transmettre des valeurs
derrière ça va tout seul et moi c'est ce
qui s'est passé après un là comme je le
dis il ya un retour de de pas mal de
toxico etc
c'est juste pour les jeunes coincés pas
c'est pas très tôt pour les jeunes mais
bon nous en tout cas on essaie de faire
notre travail de notre association pour
voilà les pousser vers le sport les
diriger vers pas mal de choses et c'est
de faire des sorties avec eux et c'est
de l'art voilà un clic et pas mal de
valeur au niveau du sport et nous par
exemple là vous allez voir tout à l'air
et à pas mal de jeunes qui fument ou qui
faisait pas mal de choses et lorsque
sont mis à la boxe en voyant jeux
olympiques ça les a motivés c'est
incroyable ça les a motivés ça les a
boostés et encore une fois ça a créé des
vocations il y en a énormément devenu
coach d'autres tirs sont ceux qui voient
là ils n'ont pas lâché la motion des
compétitions extérieures
même s'ils sont pas dans le
ça leur crée une occupation ça leur
permet de s'épanouir
c'est top en tout cas moi c'est une
crise c'est ce qu'on appelle le parc le
parquet après un décalage est ce que ce
serait c'est ce qu'on veut éviter aux
jeunes atteints d'un décalage en creuse
entre les et une toxico etc
les plus sains les jeunes qui les
joueurs jouent tous les jours froids
lagarde et l'autre à toulouse où moi je
suis là
9h04 ont déjà commencé presque comme une
reprise en blanc les gens font plus que
j'allais je vois quand j'étais plus
jeune j'allais craquer un carnet
d'entraînement avant entre le foot et la
boxe après une chose est sûre qui j'ai
bon
[Musique]
je
la vocation de ce qu'ils en font pas du
tout là qu'ils trouvent une ou deux fois
ils ont du cadencement sont des
partenaires mais petit à petit se mettre
en forme
ce traitement le plus sacré des
champions donc gelé les salaires qui ont
décrit de champion de la vie de tous les
jours